all right so how about we start with
some questions from Twitter I actually
think this one might have been on
Facebook so Brady Simpson asked how do
we deal with the ever-increasing
pressure from governments trying to get
into devices Tom do you have an opinion
on this one I do so I think one of the
most important things to think about is
that some of this is just legislation
based however some vendors do actually
care about the privacy and security of
their users Apple has been pretty good
about it
Microsoft has actually done a lot of
work for this previously when blackberry
was still a thing they were basically
number one
but right now apples pretty much the
most consumer friendly in terms of
security for just your personal devices
they give you a lot of options they do a
lot of stuff behind the scenes to make
it really easy the your passcode is
actually backed by some really really
cool stuff you know your fingerprint
reader on your phone is pretty pretty
simple it works pretty much all the time
so you know that that's easy security
stuff the government trained to subpoena
the information from your devices is a
lot bigger can of worms and it kind of
goes back to you know the Constitution
is essentially like fourth fourth
amendment Fifth Amendment stuff so
search and seizure is really kind of up
in the air with electronic devices you
know this this kind of goes all the way
back to the 1960s in terms of personal
privacy in the 60s the government came
up with something called Ashkelon I
believe and you know that was basically
trying to get data to spy on spies you
know in the in the 90s it was you know
Clinton trying to do stuff to catch more
spies basically and with email and stuff
becoming more and more prevalent they
just you know put in this jain apparatus
to do surveillance on the american
population so vendors when they tactical
this kind of have to go well what can we
do without you know taking off the
government Apple's done a good job of
basically saying no we're
not gonna give you the keys to things
you know if you want to get into
somebody's phone you're gonna have to
basically get around the protections
we've put in because we don't want to
make something that's intentionally and
secure and and they've done pretty well
with that they've gotten some flack from
some people but so as a lay person like
what precautions are you taking with
your own data I think for the most part
you know as long as you use the the key
code and you know any sort of like
biometric authentication on your on your
devices you're in a good spot if you
don't do any of that you're kind of
you're just kinda in the wind you know
the government has pretty deep ability
to surveil you so your phone is probably
not really gonna be the vector they go
after the most unless you're sending
encrypted messages and stuff if you've
got signal they probably want to see
what you're doing but if they can
subpoena you and you don't have you know
good protection on your phone you're
just there they're gonna see what's
there they can't they can't make Apple
decrypt what what you've got if you've
got an Android phone you're much less
well-off so it's really just you know
legislation and you know using good
technology I believe the the pixel eight
or the what are the the the new Samsung
phone has some pretty neat stuff built
into it it's got good security what
about you Leah do you do anything in
particular I'm actually so I have an
iPhone and I'm I have some little
paranoia things like I know how to turn
off the phone so if I was like panicked
so so I do actually just got the iPhone
10 so hi have the facial recognition but
I've always had I always tend to get the
latest iPhone so I had the touch ID as
well and the interesting thing is I
think it's much easier for law
enforcement to access your phone via
touch ID like you're saying through
touch ID or facial recognition but the
nice thing Apple does is if you have
three failed attempts or if you shut off
your phone you have to re-enter your
passcode
that's much harder for them to access so
I've practiced like powering down my
phone I I tend to only put one of my
thumbs in the thumbprint so that if I
needed to I could use my other thumb and
just pretend like oh it's just I'm
nervous it's not working until it locks
me out I don't know is that all weird
and paranoid but that's great but I feel
like it's the price you pay you know
it's like the trade-off for using some
of the convenience features yeah but
what about on the company side so it
breaker how do you guys think about
security sure that's a great question
so we basically follow sort of standard
web service practices we have an API in
the backend on the front end basic iOS
stuff so big sticking a big thing for me
is keeping private data in the keychain
it's an iOS developer and not in any
other local files especially not in NS
user defaults or putting it in info dot
P list so I don't put stuff in there you
can unzip an app directory to look at
anyone's info.plist
which is great like I actually use it to
find out what other apps are doing for
certain like Apple specific settings
because they have like these weird
configurations that you can do for like
um interoperability with other apps and
it never seems to work so I was just
like download people's but yeah yeah
just making sure that as an app
developer when you're storing sensitive
data such as passwords usernames any PII
personally identifying information about
people that you are doing so in a
thoughtful way and you know I think
there are a lot of best practices about
this and I'm not I don't want to go into
all of them but it's pretty easy to just
google and find out what they all are
and just to be aware of it just to know
that you have sensitive data and power
and to be really aware of that you have
a responsibility as an app developer to
protect that data and for actually is
interesting I was thinking about cloud
services and the government accessing
cloud services and for my last job is at
Dropbox and a lot of other companies do
this as well they publish all of the
requests from the government so the
legal team publishes them all online
through like a disclosure report every
year
so you can you can see what what kids
asked for but yeah and it's part of the
the the most companies today who are
behaving well don't want to be overly
generous with providing data to the
government but under certain legal
conditions it is necessary so but making
that all very transparent to users when
you sign up for a service knowing sort
of how they deal with government
requests cool well let's go to Brady's
second question then so he asked why is
auth tech changing every few years from
you be keys to two-factor off to
thumbprint to face recognition
what are we optimizing for speed and
reliability or security what's next or
just what's cool yeah honestly like the
face I do you think I think I like the
an emoji like making yeah I think I like
that more than the actual security part
of it but uh yeah it's a straight off
between convenience and security right
so I think a lot of these new
technologies coming out are for
convenience no I would say here Tom's
thoughts on these things too I mean all
this stuff is actually really old it's
just a the thing that we're actually
using it now
like I went back and looked and a two
factor auth you know kind of started
with one-time passwords that stuff was
originated in the 1880s so like it's
really not new really what it is is
people are becoming more aware of their
own security they want to make sure that
you know whatever personal data they
have doesn't you know get out there like
most people have really terrible
passwords and they're sort of like oh
okay even if I have this terrible
password you know if I use this little
thing it'll keep my my personal data
save and I think that's good I mean I
don't think that you know the way that
we implemented is necessarily you know
what matters I think it's just the fact
that people are using it more and
becoming more aware you know I think I
think speed and reliability are really
important when you look at what's
available I think if you go back like I
have a laptop from the 90s that has a
fingerprint reader on it
you never really used it but but it was
the thing that you could use it worked
pretty well actually you know now
there's just it's more ubiquitous
there's more
you know multi-factor authentic
you know looking forward I think we'll
even see probably like a DNA ID
I mean sensors are getting smaller and
smaller all the time you know you can
detect so many different factors like
humans have you know unique chemical
fingerprints even so you could have
something where it's like oh my phone
smells me or something yeah what's
interesting about this is that like it's
not just that - like we talked about
two-factor authentication what it really
is is multi-factor authentication and
having those factors be of different
types
I'm gonna try and remember the different
types but there is something is
something you know something you are
like biometric and what's the what's
another one something you have so device
so device biometric and something you
remember like a password and so having
two different factors I think is the key
for two-factor authentication so like a
UB key is a device or if you have
Authenticator on your phone like an
Authenticator app that's that's like a
device one the thumbprint facial
recognition is biometrics and those pros
and cons to each right so what I find
super interesting is I love the
convenience of the face and the
thumbprint but what's really nice about
the device and something you remember is
you can replace it so if it were to get
stolen so if someone takes a cast of
your thumbprint it's a lot harder to
change your thumbprint then change your
password change your face so a nice nice
security feature is the ability to
change something if you feel like it's
been compromised to make a new password
or to change up your device the device
was a huge pain in the ass because every
time I get a new iPhone I spend the next
like hour switching over all my
Authenticator keys it's like oh my god
yeah
I just did it did you read the post
about the the mask faking out the iPhone
X yeah have you tried to replicate it
you have masks making materials
yeah but it's super scary because it's
not like you're gonna change your nose
right so having it as a second factor or
having down as the I guess it's the
first factor right it's the first
protection but having the passcode is
the backup for that is super important
okay huh something that you can change
right yeah I've just been wondering if
there's like a line for you guys where
you're like you know what face ID I'm
good
like I don't need this right now because
I'm gonna like just like you said
there's a point at which if someone
hacks you or figures out a way or some
exploit it's open forever
are there certain like or is the
convenience also for security minded
people just so high that you opt into it
I love the convenience so I'm a big one
password user so i don't i don't
actually know any of my passwords it set
my one password and now it's two taps i
think you tap once on the button that
says look up my password and it does the
face or watch cognition okay and then
you tap the password that you want to
enter it's just because it knows what
site it's on or whatever and it's just
so fast it's just tap tab whereas you
know I've been using password manager
for ages and it's such a pain to like
switch apps like get the password copy
it paste it in yeah so it is the
conveniences phenomenal but what is the
risk that I hope no one takes a mask of
my face do you use any would add two
factor devices or biometric stuff yeah I
mean I well I don't do as much data
center stuff anymore but you know
definitely done a lot of biometric off
stuff funnily enough a buddy of mine was
the first person to break the the touch
ID on the on the iPhone he also recently
published something about the guys who
did the mask thing I would do you mean
by break you like copied someone's
fingerprint basically yeah I mean
there's a few things that Apple did to
try to make sure that there's some
liveness and some other stuff but you
know it's hardware at the end of the day
so it's not you know it's a little
fallible but it's it's not bad yeah like
there's the setting on the eye for the
facial recognition where if your eyes
are closed it won't read your face which
is really creative
I assume that's like to protect yourself
you could just close your eyes it's so
obvious it's not like the left thumb
right thumb thing that you're talking
about like if you show your phone to
your face
and you close your eyes someone's no
knows that you're trying to fake it I
guess but I guess did you guys know I
don't know to someone
Tom asked specifically about YC and so
Rick Deacon asked what precautions is YC
take to protect data so I mean we we
deploy you know best practices we don't
do anything you know super super scary
you know we just make sure that we know
where our users are we make sure that
people use strong passwords we use you
know strong encryption VPN yeah VPN is
an easy one you know we have some
dedicated hardware and stuff for VP
annings so that that is kind of a little
harder just to you know remotely get
into you but you know but best practice
stuff we stick to it you know we do not
you know have nuclear secrets or
anything like that so you know I'm not
worried about someone parachuting in
with you know machine guns and chainsaws
you know our stuff is pretty it's pretty
open I mean if you're a YC founder your
data is well protected um and we want to
make sure that that stays that way but
you know we're not gonna you know do DNA
ID to get into something right so you
know we we do we do a pretty good job of
just making sure that everything's
pretty button down and code views that's
kind of the biggest thing mm-hmm
you know it's it's all pretty pretty
easy our developers are great so we're
we're lucky in that aspect so yeah it's
a really good team so that helps I would
agree with that Rick also asked another
question he asks what is the future of
security for startups do you guys have
strong opinions here I think there's a
good trend of people just not
reinventing the wheel for security
reinventing the wheel is pretty much the
worst thing you can do I mean ever
time we see you know a big hack it's
because if somebody did something but
they're like oh I'm gonna be really
clever and reinvent this thing and like
cool you know you forgot this one thing
where if you add an extra zero or
something like oh hey look this password
isn't clear so that that that happens I
think outsourcing auth is a really
important thing you know a lot is great
you know sam'l is create most companies
don't really need to worry about ah you
know in in that way you know Facebook
auth is great it's ubiquitous it's
pretty solid
you know well-run company you know it's
it's it's everywhere you don't need to
reinvent that wheel hmm I think you know
moving forward like really it's just
gonna be what companies need you know
most startups don't need you know crazy
military-grade stuff they don't need
HSMs they don't need TPMS even your
phone is a TPM in in it but like you
know it's so ubiquitous that that you
don't need it so having you know
something like OAuth just removes the
need for really traina have to build in
a lot of security you know beyond that a
lot of CI is continuous integration
software's have you know things where
you could just sort of turn on like code
checking you can do you know easy easy
balance checking you can do a lot of
security stuff just automatically and
it's really nice you know you don't even
I mean most developers do care somewhat
about it but you know when you get the
intern in and they're like oh yeah you
know I wrote this great function that
you know has you know want one thing in
it right like they're not necessarily
gonna know yeah so that's why having
some oversight is good but you know
frameworks eliminate a lot of these
problems there's a lot of really great
frameworks out now I think really now
more than ever there's a lot of just a
lot of really good stuff you know has
some pretty interesting stuff in it just
in terms of you know programming level
security you know I made the joke the
other day that you know if you're if you
need random numbers the best way to get
them is is to use a language that
doesn't have any sanity check you know a
new developer yes because they won't
even know that they don't that they need
to do memory management there's
something already there so yeah Leah
would you advise the same thing I
totally agree with Tom I think when
you're looking to build a website or an
app or something to use best practices
is the way to go and these things are
sort of open standards and open
protocols for a reason
because large teams that people work on
it so I worked on o auth the first
version may be not as good as subsequent
versions but worked on the first version
Vaduz it was a large team I'd say at any
given time we had you know 20 30 people
working on different parts of it and I'm
personally not a security expert I'm a
security hobbyist so it was fun to work
with folks from like Google Yahoo mint
comm like financial institutions who
definitely had more at stake in terms
rather than I was working on a social
network at the time a little less at
stake than financial data but it was
nice to have them sanity check
especially all the algorithms for
hashing and to make sure that like we
were kind of doing things in a way that
could protect against known attacks and
things that people knew were like you
know vulnerabilities and vectors but
nowadays like as a just an app or web
developer you don't have to think about
any of that right like you've to use
facebook login it's like you download an
SDK and you like follow the instructions
and it just works and it's secure and
fantastic and at least like Facebook
deal with that right it's really great
but that being said I do think there is
still room to innovate on sort of the
user experience side of security so
that's when we talk about things like
face IDE or like sort of new and what
can we do now that we couldn't do you
know ten years ago that we would have
liked to write so some of that stuff is
fun to play with I'm really interested
so after working on oh I'm still really
interested in sort of like user login
and all of the especially preventing
against targeted attacks is like one of
my like fun hobbies and so some of the
stuff you see now that I'm super
interested in is when when you log in on
a new device mmm that you get in
email about it if your password changes
that you get notified how do you prevent
you know someone changing the email
address and changing the password at the
same like too close together some of
those things are just like product
things to think about like if you're
developing a product that you need to be
secure like what can you do in the case
of both sort of just general attacks to
get data from your database or the more
like targeted attacks which is kind of I
don't know why that's interesting to me
I just find it like fascinating
especially in the age of like Instagram
celebrities and things like I think it's
pretty interesting and and people in
general aren't super good about security
so how can we as app developers protect
someone in the case that they do have a
terrible password well I think you saw
it you know with people porting phone
numbers for crypto stuff in particular
those are giant those are horrible it
really brought to attention how bad the
cell phone companies were prepared for a
multi-factor authentication like I don't
use my phone for for multi-factor
authentication I would highly recommend
against it you mean SMS yeah not using
SMS or phone calls or anything like that
as a fact as effect as a factor so use
Google Authenticator yeah
yeah or a similar apple juice man
there's like authy there's some other
ones they're pretty good okay hmm
or you bequite your other options I just
think you know like when you were lying
on someone who gets probably paid
minimum wage just to sort of like be
phone support I don't know if I would be
counting on that you know totally and do
you crypto thoughts in general so safe I
told you this before the podcast Tom I
get a name wrong every time say Phil LA
he asked what are the most recent
security concerns in crypto our crypto
currency just to be clear I think really
it's just you know it's new people are
getting used to it
you know people are sort of inventing
their own languages to go along with
them you know what we were talking about
earlier with the theory and the other
week where somebody kind of deleted a
really important function of a contract
you know that that that stuff will
happen
and you know people will just you know
take that lesson and move on
I don't think crypto currencies are
necessarily more or less secure than
anything else
I mean cash if you leave it on a table
somebody's probably gonna run off with
it you know we saw a lot of early
Bitcoin stuff go away because people
were using like horribly insecure
hosting stuff you know hopefully people
don't continue that but I'm sure it will
I mean people leave their wallets with
you know passwords alike one two three
four on their laptops
some people will I have seen wallets
stored on public anonymous FTP sites
with like a password of like one you
know you it's like basic stuff I mean
you know you can't protect users from
themselves really I don't think I don't
think crypto specifically has a problem
I think it's interesting to see how
people are using it I think it's kind of
nice that you know you can have it be so
ubiquitous and it's sort of like a it
sort of brings power back to the people
who use it a little bit versus like with
cash or like Oh central bank you know
you have to do this but I'm not a crypto
libertarian on this issue at all yeah I
actually I'm fascinated by I love the
blockchain as a technology from like a
database ledger kind of perspective and
actually I have a podcast to recommend
since I we're kind of there's a show
called invest like the best and they
have a three part series called hash
power and it's on the technology behind
the blockchain and Bitcoin and also
investing and I think they have a couple
other topics that they cover sort of
like kind of a broad look at everything
to do with cryptocurrency and I loved it
because I I didn't I knew sort of the
general idea but I didn't know like the
history or like so much in depth about
it but it was excellent and what is
interesting to me personally is
distributed versus centralized systems
and how they play out
I feel like the blockchain is the first
really distributed system we've seen
become quite popular in recent memory I
mean the Internet itself as a large
distributed systems I can't say it like
the only really interesting good system
but what we've been seeing with the
Internet is a centralization like we've
been seeing centralized powers
especially with the large tech companies
now really consolidating right like
Facebook having eight of the top ten
apps and the eye in the app store right
so they like large amassing of power and
user data with very few companies and
what's interesting to me about the
blockchain is taking that back a little
bit and there is some centralization
around the blockchain like there are
like mining conglomerates there are
services that will host and store your
data for you so cloud services instead
of using like a physical device to store
your private keys you could use a cloud
service and what's interesting about
that is like the insurance factor of it
so when you think about like banks and
how your money is insured seeing these
companies come up with like now we're
gonna insure cryptocurrency and it's
like ooh this is interesting right it's
basically like rebuilding a banking
system built for like the Internet age
it's really it's super interesting and
I'm not sure how it's all gonna play out
and I agree some of the biggest security
concern right now and say the number one
is user error right I totally agree with
that I think that that the fact that
it's decentralized kind of protects
against a lot of like fraud or malicious
intent by by centralized power but it
makes it really hard to recover your
data if anything happens yeah so it's
fascinating yeah so I mean it's kind of
like measure twice cut once before you
send someone a bunch of aetherium yes
this has happened a bunch on just
private slacks around I cos people post
fake it like they'll steal the avatar
from the creator and create an account
in that slack and then post an address
like a minute before the ICO will happen
and it's like this torrent of money
flows to them and that's all let's get
and and it's like there you go gone yeah
Wow yeah yeah just be very careful I
don't know I have no idea how one
establishes trust with corrupt
currencies other than by using
centralized systems that's very
difficult yeah I don't know well you did
mention podcast and we should talk about
podcast here so let's jump up to cats
question so cat mini Alec partner will I
see through a question out let's start
with the first part what are your
favorite podcasts oh that's a great
question and actually my my big thing is
I want to just put a plug for a breaker
here follow me on breaker you can easily
see what my favorite podcasts are what's
great about breaker is it's social you
can see what people are listening to you
can see what they subscribe to you can
see what people are liking you can see
what podcast episodes are hot actually I
found this hash power series because it
became popular on breaker it got a lot
of attention a lot of comments and it's
not I wouldn't listen to a podcast
called invest like the best yeah but it
was an interesting series so um
podcasts that don't exist that I wish
did I think there's like right now on
breaker it's a lot of tech it's a lot of
startups it wasn't that in the early
days with few users we have more
true-crime comedy mm-hm
so what I guess what I'd like is I
personally love storytelling
so I'd like to hear more diverse stories
so stories from people you wouldn't
normally hear on podcasts I guess that
would be my request so if you out there
are listener and you think you have
something unique to say go for it before
we go further Tom did you have a
favorite podcast so don't really do a
lot of podcasts but I think my my
favorite sort of equivalent of that is
it's called the life of Boris um
it's about this you know Slovak like
YouTube dude who that hosts like videos
and like does a bunch of Q&A with his
fans it's uh it's pretty funny because
it basically you know harkens back to a
lot of the sort of Cold War era stuff
it's it's kind of fun it's it's pretty
goofy um you know he talks about all
kinds of stuff like you know the gamut
of like video games cars you know
cooking like other
learned how to cook a bunch of Russian
stuff from it so like you know I kind of
like that that kind of variety hmm but
otherwise I mean I think the podcasts
that are missing for me are just like
really in-depth like security stuff
there's a lot more like blogging around
that kind of stuff because you can't
really show like a breadboard on on yeah
on a podcast right but you know I
definitely would like to find out about
it so I'm definitely you know interested
in in ways that I can find new stuff so
I'm definitely gonna probably spend a
little more time quicker requests for
security podcasts there I listen to a
ton of Swift podcasts and a couple
Python ones and I've been less able to
find more general security DevOps
that sort of thing so they like that's
definitely an area that someone could
make a box
yeah I've been so impressed with a
breaker search that's my favorite part
by far yeah I really like that so cat
asked a second question and she asked
what mistakes did you make with your
first company that you know not to
repeat on the second and Tom as a
founder as well so this is a valid
question for both yeah Oh mistakes I
don't know I mean like let's see I've
been doing startups since I was like 15
years old so I've seen a lot of mistakes
I think one of the the biggest ones is
just poorly spending your money I worked
at a start-up where we had a shag carpet
walled music room I'm pretty sure that I
knew what else happened there no we
spent ridiculous amounts of money on
things we bought Napster for like a
month
what yeah yeah right I know absolutely
required Napster acquired Nasir gave it
back so like there's all kinds of weird
stuff like that that happened in you
know sort of like the early boom you
know now I think money even though it's
pretty easily available to entrepreneurs
I think you know it's still paying
attention to where you spend your money
is is key like you know some of some of
PGs early stuff about you know like
don't don't go get an office work out of
your house you know a lot of the YC
ethos is really really stuff that I
recommend people stick to because it's
just it's so easy to be like oh yeah I
got all this money I'm gonna go get a
flashy car I'm gonna go get a nice
office I'm gonna go you know by the by
the best screens and stuff for me and
then they just spend their time you know
derping around on like trying to be like
whatever they they feel like makes them
a successful founder rather rather than
yeah playing startup scene stirring I
think is kind of another good term for
it I mean that those parties are fun but
they don't they don't get your company
anywhere yes oh yes yes I'm the opposite
I'm so frugal all of my startups are
pretty much around on I don't know
steam air so yeah we're still even
breaker is still very frugal as a
company but I've definitely had other
other issues my one is sort of the
opposite it's asking for help so going
out and trying to build I think I've
always thought oh I can build it I
should just build it as opposed to how
do I get other people involved in my
company how do I have other people care
about this how can we build something
better together how can I listen more to
users how can you know and now
everything we do with breaker is super
user feedback focused it's just what do
people want let's just build what
everyone wants and it's just a totally
different approach than I'm building
something that I want for myself right
so it and it's been much more rewarding
like building things because people
actually are asking you for them it's
just so it's easy to do it's a little
hard to get over the ego of like oh
there's a bug here and someone's talking
about it or hey if you don't have this
feature yet I'm sorry but that's really
been a huge huge change for me the the
other thing is more personal my first
few startups I struggled with myself as
a founder and not really fitting the
mold of what I thought a start-up
founder would be like same for a
developer starting off even as a
developer like I used to get these
programming books that were like like
developers like us and they'd have
pictures on the front that looks nothing
like me
say it's figuring out it's not just like
the way I look but it's also my
personality like I don't feel like I am
a start-up founder but that is also sort
of coming to terms with that is like I
have this mantra every day that I get up
and I say it can only be the best person
that I am like sort of be true to myself
and that I don't have to be exactly like
Steve Jobs or Mark Zuckerberg or Elon
Musk right like I'm I'm not that's never
gonna happen I would say that's also a
good thing yeah yeah yeah but you know
there are definitely like a wider
variety of writers out there that don't
get as much like glory in the brothers
in the media that are still phenomenal
founders running huge companies just
maybe less less exciting them yeah or
just like less flashy or I mean it's a
chance and maybe running a business
that's not particularly sexy which is
always hard
so you mentioned user testing now that
you guys are a little bit bigger than
you were during YC you like giving it to
me and being like hey what do you like
about it yeah how are you doing user
testing at a larger scale now yeah we
have several different ways that we
collect data from users we have just an
in-app bug reporting tool it's kind of
most direct you can actually just send
us an email if you take a screenshot in
the app it actually prompts you like hey
did you see a bug do you want to send it
to us which is great it's a tool called
bug life so we love bug life we use
Mixpanel for implicit user testing and
this is actually I would say almost more
valuable than what people tell you is
what they do so we use it for things
like testing retention doing funnels so
knowing like when people drop off in a
particular like if we want them to take
a particular action what happens that
they tend to not do that a bee testing
so we actually we don't do a ton of a/b
testing but we do with things like
search and discovery do more a/b testing
and sort of like what do people actually
want here what are they actually tapping
on what are they listening to what gets
them excited so those are probably our
two biggest tools for collecting user
feedback we are starting to do more like
user experience testing and we're about
to send out our first like survey
we time I always a little bit like
survey like I like that people reach out
and give us like feedback directly we
get a lot a lot of email feedback have
there been any surprises and like the
the product you designed and how it was
and ended up being used oh yeah
definitely um I'm trying to think of a
good example but there's like stuff
every day that just you know the way
that I use a podcast app is not the way
that everyone else does and we've sort
of in our mind have this like ideal user
of who you want to be a breaker user and
it's not like a hardcore podcast
listener we're not on the extreme of the
spectrum like you're listening to
podcasts all day and you're very fussy
about your settings but on the other
hand it's it's someone that we want to
be more long-term engaged with the
product so it's not just someone who's
going to drop in and listen to one
episode we really want to you know get
people into podcasting and get people
into listening to podcasts the same way
that you would like watching Netflix
right like we want people to be as
excited about a new episode of their
favorite show as a podcast as they are
the next episode which is exciting and
really fun and I I think there's a lot
of room for podcasts to grow to really
fit that and I hope that breaker can be
part of that like the whole industry of
podcasting needs to grow in order for it
to be a really exciting business
opportunity I mean I think it's 250
million a year now in like ad revenues
which is like tiny considering how much
people talk about podcasts yes yes I
think there's definitely room to grow
and that was one of the reasons I
started breakers I was looking for a
market that wasn't saturated that wasn't
that was growing but could be
accelerated by young technology why do
you think the iOS podcast app is so
popular because it comes installed on
the phone by define no but Apple Maps is
garbage in it like Apple Maps got
usurped by Google Maps right I guess it
might be better now I think you said
yeah well hopefully breaker will take
over and this is what we're going for
it's like how do you become better than
what comes installed on the phone and
that's it's it's a hard problem yeah
okay fun one absolutely yeah and so
backtracks who is actually our podcast
host they treated at you they asked
what's the most difficult challenge in
podcast discovery
so for I have a very strong opinion on
this all right I will lay it out there
we do episode discovery not show
discovery the distinction there is there
are a lot of podcasts being produced
these days where a particular episode
will really get you so it's more topic
based episodes or story based episodes
there's a couple there's a few podcasts
that are like many podcasts that are
serialized formats or have like a longer
story to tell but when we're talking
about individual stories I think what
gets people hooked on a podcast is a
good story it's like watching a good
clip of SNL right like sometimes you
just want to know what the good good
parts are so for us we want to highlight
the good episodes based on users liking
them listening to them commenting on
them and that's what we highlight in
Breaker it's it's what is hot right now
not based on like so Apple uses editors
they have people who go in and say hey
you should like this show because we as
an Apple editor think it then it's like
I just want to know what's the best
episode right now like what's the one
that everyone's listening to yeah and so
Allen Lee so you mentioned H Netflix
before Netflix of podcast only asks I
love breaker housebreaker going to be
the Netflix of podcasting in the future
Allen Leigh with the long term vision
basically giving our pitch so that's
that's that's sort of what we are our
goal is to become this source of really
great content what I find interesting is
I think that podcasts are getting better
in quality in terms of the storytelling
in the shows but I don't know that
they've quite reached the level of the
game of throwing a game of Thrones of
podcasts that's when we talk about a lot
it's like right now we're seeing some of
these really good podcasts but we
haven't hit the show I mean we've had
cereal which was a big big popular show
a big popular podcast but we're you know
and and it's really a chicken-and-egg
problem like if we had that show would
it be just distributed across all
podcast networks could we actually make
money off of that kind of show if we had
a show big enough but is there a big
enough audience on breaker yet to make
it interesting to have a big show so I
think we're kind of taking the approach
of trying to gain a lot
audience using breaker and then be able
to present them with unique content that
we that you know is of the quality of
something like a Game of Thrones
house of cards I mean it's a challenge I
mean even hardcore history is like five
episodes a year and it's him and other
like staff working on that show yeah
it's it's difficult to produce but it's
actually much cheaper and easier to
produce a podcast than a television show
it's like a hundred acts more expensive
to produce a television show than to
produce a podcast a quality podcast are
you working on your own yet original
content I am NOT I don't make I'm
definitely on the technical side I have
much respect for people who are
storytellers I actually just went to a
live podcast taping this weekend or a
live podcast show they were actually
playing back an episode that they hadn't
dared um I've loved and radio showed up
but uh it was it's super interesting and
I got to talking afterwards about
storytelling and how it in itself is a
skill and I just don't have any time to
work on developing developing that but
Craig you you have do you feel like your
strategy has evolved over time sort of
like given feedback from listeners and
how have you how does the podcast
changed um so this is the second podcast
I've done
so the first podcast I did was called
salt of the earth and we interviewed
small business owners that were funny
and it was a great podcast I had a lot
of fun doing it but finding guests was
really hard especially because they're
often you know just obscure small
business owners and so not only is that
difficult but then distribution becomes
a real challenge so that's super hard
like distribution across like almost
every podcast is super difficult so with
this one we do YouTube and YouTube works
really well aside from that my strat
like in terms of host style I don't know
what you mean yeah yeah your approach to
how you do interviews because it uses
both interview shows right yeah they're
both interview shows I've recognized how
important it is to control the energy in
the room and as the host it's totally on
you a lot of people think
I'll just bring in Lee and Tom and
they're gonna be super fun this is gonna
be great and you are both super fun but
that's not the case like you have to
collect a Vassar ton energy about you
and keep it going
transitioning is always difficult
between subjects and I think one thing
that's maybe obvious to the listeners
and the two people is that I introduce
people in the podcast edit rather than
having people introduce themselves
because that can be a little like it
kind of takes the air out of the room if
someone's not used to introducing
themselves oh yeah I guess would you say
that startup founders are better at
introducing themselves than
salt-of-the-earth interviewees it's
totally sales right like if you're good
at sales you can really like come and
they like make it super engaging but
more often than not people are just like
you know they're just modest right so
like both of you guys are coming as like
hey you know like I'm Lea and I work on
breaker and and it's it's cool and
everything but the reality is that you
have to you want to get someone hooked
really early on in the podcast and so
that's when the energy has to come so if
you start out with like hey Lia what do
you do yeah then it's not quite as good
so yeah I would do that we edit the
podcast I think a lot of people are like
I don't have to edit like I'll just go
and I feel like I think a lot of people
don't realize how edited a lot of the
most popular shows are oh yeah I just an
interview on a show called hack to start
they edit them I didn't realize it
because it has a very natural interview
type feel so I'd listen to a few
episodes and I went on the show and so I
then could compare what I said versus
what came out and it's so much better
what came up very heavily edited without
sounding edited which I thought was
amazing and I know you do a little less
editing it's not that much yeah yeah I
really admire Joe Rogan's podcast cuz
like they can keep like a three-hour
conversation like at high energy and fun
and they transition pretty well and
that's something that I've been trying
to get better at doing but it's
difficult especially with video right
because the continuity becomes an issue
if you're just like cutting all over the
place whereas if you looked at the the
time and like the time something was
recorded for the serial and then like
placed it back into the episode it's all
over the place yeah
actually that's something I wish I saw
more podcast do so another request for
podcast is to incorporate music legally
of course sounds sort of using exploring
audio more as an art form
I've definitely listen to some pieces
that that do that and it does make a
huge difference it's not necessarily the
best thing for like interview type shows
but there are shows and stories you can
tell we're adding those elements in
really helps yeah I would also say to
podcasters definitely transcribe your
stuff because Google is not friendly to
audio and you want that like indexed
stuff right there it's pretty cheap to
do which is actually something we're
thinking about starting to do for
breaker two and get into like future
ideas we have some pretty crazy ideas
yeah I mean if you can talk about it
let's do it so we do want to eventually
transcribe podcasts that that are on
breaker which is pretty much every
podcast however right now there's some
options where you can pay to have things
transcribed either by a human or robot
to varying degrees of success but
they're fairly expensive and cost
prohibitive for something like breaker
where millions of episodes what else you
guys want to talk about mmm I found a
company doing what what I did with
Kripke sealant when he's living now and
like that they have more adoption it's
kind of funny they're called NF ki and
they're basically doing secret
management for app developers I I love
all of the I think there's a huge
opportunity in security to do sort of
secret management like right now things
are just like I'll put in an N variables
like so bad and for us as soon as you
have a team of more than like two people
you need to be sharing all sorts of
private information and with companies
it's like if someone joins the company
you got to set it all up if they leave
like you have to somehow like revoke all
these tokens right so it's pretty
terrible right now I think there's a
huge opportunity there yeah I mean that
that was the thing that we tried to
address with crypto seal was that you
know we it all felt the pain of managing
secrets and stuff like that and some
secrets were more secret than others
you know but you know it's still a tough
problem it's still something that
developers hate to deal with you know
people still share passwords and like
spreadsheets and stuff like that which
which just kind of makes me run like
hide my head my hands but you know
there's there's technology coming out
there for it
I believe lyft actually like published
something that's actually kind of useful
and it's pretty interesting you know I
mean like this is an area where like I
have a lot of background because like
I've got a patent on at all but you know
it's it's interesting to see what things
come back around in terms of security
but password management still it's a
huge problem nobody really does it all
that well especially for developers it's
a huge pain in the butt so anything that
makes that easier I'm I'm all in for so
that that's kind of neat you know beyond
that I think you know if somebody wants
to fund a DNA sensor for your phone I
think that's probably going to be a good
market I know that there's there's some
companies out there doing some more sort
of weird like bio aware sensors and I
think that'll be that'll be pretty
interesting you know if you look at you
know the last five years with people
paying attention to all their sort of
personal metrics and stuff like
everybody's got a Fitbit everybody's got
something that you know tracks whatever
their steps or whatever I think that
stuff is gonna be pretty interesting
it's gonna get more in-depth you know
five years we'll probably have a scale
that'll be like oh you you know should
probably cut out eating this or you
should eat more this or something like
that I think we'll see some pretty
interesting consumer technologies come
out of you know weird potentially
security stuff so if you weren't working
at YC what startup would you work on I'm
gonna start start I mean I definitely
think that there's a lot of room for
more security stuff I think there's a
lot more things that can be done with
like end user metrics if you go back and
look at like a like a good example for
security as DDoS it's still a thing like
it's been around forever you know the
the first big DDoS I remember was
against eBay in like 1997 or something
that's 20 years ago right now so this is
still a problem they're just getting
bigger and bigger and bigger you know my
my current you know method of mitigation
is telling people to go get CloudFlare
it's the simplest thing you know I think
there's gonna be more stuff in that
space especially as people you know
start publishing more interesting things
you know I kind of think that the
Internet's still in its infancy in a way
because you know
yeah Facebook is kind of like micro
blogging for everybody but it's really
not it's not that ubiquitous you know
people you know Instagram actually is a
little bit more ubiquitous people you
know take pictures of their food all the
time and like then well that's kind of
mmm whatever it is it's it's interaction
I think we'll have people doing more
sort of like life blogging kind of stuff
and I think when we see more of that
we'll get a lot more interesting
perspectives on people yeah yeah I love
this thought and I love that you're
getting into sort of like biometrics and
I I loved passive sharing as a concept
and there aren't very many apps
currently that do it so people say oh
how could there be another social
network and and something I'm fascinated
by and haven't seen it done super well
is like so so for example breaker and
like things like Spotify tell you you
know what you've listened to and show
other people what you've listened to in
the past and is like a passive behavior
not like intentionally sharing that but
there was for a while I think path did
some really interesting stuff with
passive sharing sort of if you had sort
of these monitors turned on you could
sort of publish that right now a lot of
the health data and sensors even things
like Fitbit aren't extremely social you
can kind of see other people step counts
but they're not everything that you
could potentially be sharing but it's
like it's questions of so what is
interesting to see I'm like kind of a
lurker so I love like my favorite part
of breakers like seeing what people
listen to
oh that's so interesting is there
incognito and breaker so we're actually
really discussing that pretty heavily
right now we've got a lot of users so
when we were very small we didn't get as
much request for privacy and and now
we're getting a lot more and so we're
figuring out how we want to do privacy
on breaker right now so if you have a
thoughts on it send us an email all
right what's your email thinking about
it feedback at breaker audio okay you
send it to feedback I actually see every
single email that goes the context they
don't think it's like going into it like
a black hole like we actually do look
look at that so if you have thoughts on
how you want privacy implemented we
really want to encourage people to share
what they're listening to and passive is
the easiest way to do it like you don't
have to think about sharing it it's not
not not tricky but then it also there's
this level of comfort like how
comfortable are you with sharing that
like I remember getting a streaming
music for the service for the first time
I actually use the are do but and like
having people see when I listen to you
it's like oh my gosh no like I don't
care I listen to Hanson's Christmas
album this winter no big deal
oh man
and if you weren't working on breaker do
you have thoughts on startup you might
be into I actually would probably work
on an open-source project I'm fascinated
with the idea of right now there's a lot
of mm I'm gonna sound really trite
saying this but like there's a mobile
and web development are pretty separate
I'm fascinated by projects like Swift on
the server and react on the device but I
think I think there's a little too
idealistic still like I think I would
want to work on practical reusability
and frameworks and I love Swift so I'd
love to get involved with what IBM is
doing with like Swift on the server so
yeah I don't know that's not super
exciting it's a I'd go a little bit more
back to like my open-source roots and
work on I'm I've never built a framework
or worked on a language and I would love
to do that yeah yeah totally cool all
right guys
so if someone wants to get into security
or building pod catchers what would you
recommend what should they check out
that there's honestly not a lot of stuff
out there
you know I used to tell people oh you
know if you're really then interested go
to DEFCON that's not really a great idea
because it's just it's it's fun but you
know the amount of learning you might
get done will probably be erased by the
amount of partying you do so you know I
think just you know trained uh like read
through blogs and stuff like that
you know honestly hacker news has some
pretty good you know security stuff to
get submitted to it
yeah hacker news is a great resource
capture-the-flag
activities have been super fun like
that's kind of how I got a little more
into it was trying that I'm still
terrible my no good at cuz it's like a
little bit beyond me but that helped me
learn some of the technical techniques
and some of the common exploits and they
set start to follow that I don't know
how close are things that you do in a
capture the flag event to like real
world security issues mmm it depends
upon how well they were set up I guess I
won't really totally go into them like
my heavy background but like there's a
lot of stuff that you can simulate
pretty easily there's a lot of there's a
lot of hilarious technology that's still
around from like when I was a kid that
people were breaking into left and right
and you you just laugh I think a good
way to to see that kind of stuff is
really you know I mean you know if you
if you want to go into the weeds you can
look through show Dan and find something
kind of interesting there and then start
to you know read up on on how it works
you know the IOT security is going to be
like a really big thing and getting
pieces of common IOT equipment is pretty
easy you know it's like maybe like 10 15
bucks you can get a little programmable
computer essentially and start poking
away at it
like I I dug into micro Python and like
submitted some patches and did some cool
stuff with some boards and like had a
lot of fun you know it cost me you know
ten bucks maybe so you can get started
pretty easily doing
some of the basics you know if you're
looking for like ways to learn how to
exploit stuff I mean you know that you
can Google you could actually insecure
org has some really great mailing list
stuff on it you can sort of see what's
what's new you know looking through new
CVEs
is kind of an interesting way of
learning about stuff there there's
really not a great way to get an intro
aside from like having somebody kind of
mentor you or essentially breaking the
law right now which I don't do not
recommend I was just like you like oh
breaking the law yeah it's like I'll
take you one step further do you have
any favorite last questions from
podcasts okay is there anything any
common philosophies and software
development or security that you
disagree with I mean there are some sort
of old-school methodologies of things
where it was really kind of security by
obscurity and like that stuff is just
mmm its BS basically you know I think if
you're if you want to be like a good
software developer like you have to you
know be good get good at you know the
tools you use regularly you know I know
like I think like three or four
programming languages I don't think
that's really super useful advice yeah I
know Lal code you know I know some
pretty silly stuff doing esoteric stuff
is not recommended on either side so I
don't think I can think of like a
methodology that would be good or bad I
think some people rely a little bit too
much maybe on like source code control I
feel like maybe the get security model
is pretty bad when you compare it to
some of the older stuff but you know the
usability you get out of it is like wait
we hire so I don't think those things
really go together I don't know yeah I
think I'd I just fall on the on the side
of being really good with your tool
rather than always looking for the
newest tool
because that that's just it's been
tiring to me with my like limited
experience as an engineer where it's
like oh you have to use this language or
this framework or this thing and just
like how about we just get really good
at Python or you know you know choose
your choose your tool but yeah that
would be mine yeah how about you that's
a really good one oh man I just had
something that I do
that was such a good one I loved it yeah
you